comment diable cette [ __ ] a-t-elle découvert nos
[ __ ] de noms que nous ne connaissons pas et le
rappelons avec le T mot pour mot vous n'êtes
pas à l'abri du service des ressources humaines
grandir c'est ce qui signifie quelque chose de
complètement différent en Angleterre eh bien
ici cela signifie  un vagin de toute façon, évidemment,
nous parlons d'une taupe, cela pourrait être une
taupe, ils auraient pu pirater notre système,
tout le monde devine que
l'essentiel est que Rayna Boyanov est
sur le point de vendre une arme nucléaire tactique à petite échelle
à une
organisation terroriste et nous ne '  Je ne sais pas où elle
ou la bombe est malheureusement notre analyste
Susan Cooper a trouvé une piste que je t'ai dit de
m'envoyer là-bas au lieu de bien et tu
ne l'as pas fait et cela trouve que je vais
te baiser, c'est ce que nous faisons je  allez
dans la machine face / off obtenez un tout
nouveau visage avez-vous des quartiers parce que cela
coûte 50 cents acheter local non parce que cela
n'existe pas